[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire en déclarant que le droit
national polonais primait sur le droit
de l'union européenne le tribunal
constitutionnel polonais a déchaîné les
foudres d'ursula von der leyen la
présidente de la commission pour qui
cela revient à s'attaquer aux fondations
de l'union européenne victor ban en a
profité pour dénoncer l'attitude de
l'union européenne envers la hongrie la
pologne digne d'après lui de la défunte
urss
le problème c'est qu'au même moment un
ancien commissaire européen nommé michel
barnier candidat à la présidentielle
chez les républicains invoquent la
souveraineté juridique de la france et
même notre conseil constitutionnel si
mais en déclarant que la loi européenne
ne peut être contraire à je cite un
principe inhérent à l'identité
constitutionnelle de la france alors qu
est-ce qu est-ce qu on ne saurait pas
tous un peu planer par les temps qui
courent pour en débattre nous avons
invité
pierre ménat qui est diplomate mais il
est pas encore arrivé
enfin passer au suivant je parle à mon
compteur évidemment max thérouanne
gastineau ancien rédacteur en chef des
pages politiques de la revue limite vous
êtes l'auteur du nouveau procès de l'est
aux éditions du cerf ve ou pourquoi
bruxelles s'oppose à budapest et à
varsovie pour vous la pologne a raison
de s'opposer là à l'union européenne
alors je pense que la pologne a raison
pour au moins deux raisons la première
raison c'est qu'en rappelant le primat
de sa constitution elle ne fait au fond
que rappeler que dans l'union européenne
il n'y a pas un peuple mais des peuples
européens comme l'a rappelé d'ailleurs à
cour de karlsruhe en 2009 l'autre rôle
de cartes rousset le tribunal le
tribunal la cour suprême allemand
l'autre raison pour laquelle je pense la
pologne a raison de s'opposer aux juges
européens
c'est qu'au fond elle nous invite tous à
nous questionner sur le sens et les
finalités du projet européen s'agit-il
au fond d'uniformiser les nations
européennes autour de valeurs non plus
communes mais similaires par le droit
par l'affirmation continue du juge
européen y compris sur des domaines qui
n'ont pas été déléguée à l'union
européenne ou s'agit-il de construire un
projet autour d' état nation qui garde
un certain nombre de marges de manoeuvre
joséphine star on vous êtes directrice
des études et des relations
internationales du think-tank si nokia
vous publier régulièrement des articles
dans l'opinion le figaro vox ou sur
atlantico notamment sur la solidarité la
cohésion dans l'union européenne alors
vous la pologne est ce qu est la raison
est ce que vous soutenez son son
initiative je pense que ce serait un peu
simplifié le des bacs de décréter que
quelqu'un raison ou tort dans cette zone
cette grande affaire un polonaise ce qui
est certain c'est qu'en tout cas la
décision de la cour constitutionnelle
polonais s'inscrit dans une une volonté
politique du gouvernement
polonais depuis son arrivée au pouvoir
en 2015 on voit régulièrement depuis ce
qu'on pourrait appeler peut-être des
provocation vis-à-vis du droit européen
mais qui s'explique de différentes
manières on aura le temps de revenir là
dessus ce qui est certain c'est que ça
interroge sur effectivement les
finalités du projet européen les
l'élargissement du droit
de l'union européenne de l'intégration
mais plus fondamentalement peut-être
s'interroge sur le concept de solidarité
européenne est ce que les états membres
sont toujours prêts aujourd'hui à
consentir et à sacrifier pour la
solidarité étienne campion vous êtes
journaliste à marianne vice-président de
ses airs sciences po c'est heureux c'est
critique de la raison européenne il
s'agit d'une association née à sciences
po de réflexion critique sur la
construction européenne sur le
libéralisme et sur la mondialisation
alors la pologne vous soutenez la
pologne dans cette peu dans cette
opposition frontale avec avec la
commission je sais pas si je soutien
mais
plutôt que de répondre
peut-être bien qu'oui peut-être bien que
non la pologne avait raison je vous
dirais que oui la pologne avait raison a
pas dire que je crois que ce
gouvernement allez bonne idée a
une vocation démocratique c'est là n'est
pas la question mais je pense que ce
moment est positif parce que c'est un
moment de clarification mon de
clarification par rapport à la question
fondamentale la plus belle question je
pense qui
appartient la philosophie politique est
celle de la démocratie
la pologne nous invite à nous poser la
question qui consiste à savoir est ce
que nos constitutions sont supérieurs au
droit européen ou pas c'est une question
fondamentale
je pense qu'on aura le temps de la porte
et
je pense que la philosophie politique
française nature de
l'art et l'instant la nature politique
française et pro fondamentalement enfin
en place le coeur de la démocratie dans
la souveraineté nationale toute la
question est là dedans la pologne dit le
même message et maintenant c'est à nous
de nous poser cette question
existentielle c'est une question
existentielle qui va falloir se poser
après cet événement polonais alors on
attend toujours l'arrivée de pierre
menad quel ancien ambassadeur feu de
france on en pologne l'ancien conseiller
de jacques chirac aux affaires
européennes il était pris dans un
embouteillage mais il va pas tarder à
nous rejoindre on va donc commencer ce
débat
thierry breton comparé la pologne en
état des etats-unis comme le thierry
breton je parle du commissaire européen
au marché intérieur il compare la
pologne à un état des etats-unis comme
le montana où le texas qui ne voudraient
plus respecté l'article 1 ou l'article 2
de la constitution américaine
mais est ce qu'on peut en parler comme
ça l'europe n'est pas un état fédéral la
pologne a atteint d'états souverains
tout comme la france d'ailleurs
est un état souverain ce que ne sont pas
le montana la californie ou où les ou le
l'ohio
et il m'a dit l'un d'eux que monsieur
breton relisent les traités puisque en
effet les traités européens rappelle que
les états sont souverains mais
transmettre à l'union européenne un
certain nombre de compétences donc la
réaction du juge polonais vise
simplement à poser un certain nombre de
limites à l'extension continue du champ
d'intervention du juge européen pourquoi
cette extension continue elle repose sur
une certaine ambiguïté ce qui fait qu'en
effet on peut peut-être pas dire que la
pologne a raison ou tort c'est un peu
plus compliqué
les traités fond d'une séparation entre
ce qui relève des états nations et ce
qui relève de nyon européenne et vous
avez ensuite des actes dérivés qui
dérivent des traités les règlements les
directives émanant de la commission de
bruxelles et puis les arrêts de la cour
de justice de l'union européenne je
prends un exemple récent l'été dernier
nous étions relativement d'accord c'est
assez rare en france sur un point le
fait que le juge européen n'avait pas à
interférer sur la manière d'organiser le
temps de travail de nos militaires jean
louis borloo qui n'est pas un
souverainiste échevelé expliqué dans une
tribune que ce n'est pas à l'union
européenne de régler le statut de nos
militaires on pourrait élargir la
question c'est à l'union européenne de
régler quoi puisque à travers un certain
nombre de directives ou à travers cette
ombre de deux décisions de la cour de
justice de l'union européenne on voit
l'union européenne intervenir sur des
domaines où il n'y a pas eu de transfert
de compétences la question de
l'organisation notre armée qui relèvent
de la sécurité nationale est un domaine
strictement régalien et l'article 4 du
traité de l'union européenne le rappel
d'aucuns diraient qu'il ya une ambiguïté
constitutifs de la construction
européenne cherche un petit peu depuis
maastricht chat ménager la chèvre
souverainiste et le chou fédéralistes
qui se retrouvent dans les traités et
qui donc occasionnent à intervalles
réguliers un certain nombre de tensions
entre gouvernement et bruxelles entre
juges nationaux et juges européens pas
qu'avec la hongrie et la pologne il faut
le souligner mais justement alors c'est
vous l'avez dit l'europe
l'union européenne n'a pas de
souveraineté puisque ces compétences
sont uniquement les compétences que lui
ont transféré des états souverains et
qui peuvent en permanence limiter ses
compétences donc là il n'y a pas de
souveraineté européenne
néanmoins dans un certain nombre parmi
ses compétences il y à la justice il y à
la liberté il y a en partie
l'immigration est une compétence
partagée donc là encore est ce que
l'europe est ce que la pologne est dans
son droit justement en l'occurrence de
s'opposer à l'union européenne là comme
elle le fait je les filme alors elle est
dans son droit
d'interroger ces principes là
effectivement comme on disait tout à
l'heure la le tribunal de karlsruhe on
met 2020 a lui aussi interrogé la
primauté du droit européen sur le droit
national en dise et le conseil
constitutionnel français l'a fait cette
semaine a fait et ce n'est pas la
première fois le danemark l'a déjà fait
la république tchèque l'a déjà fait mais
par contre ce qui est inédit dans cette
situation c'est deux choses avec la
décision du tribunal constitutionnel
polonais là le rejet on va dire du droit
communautaire est d'une ampleur tout à
fait différente que dans les autres cas
de figure pour la france la ve
république tchèque l'allemagne au
danemark c'est toujours sur des points
très précis très contextuel que que les
tribunaux se sont opposés au droit
européen la la cour de justice la fin le
coup tribunal constitutionnel polonais
dit que les articles 1 et l'article 19
du traité sur l'union européenne sont
incompatibles avec sa constitution on
n'est pas sur quelques points techniques
on est sur une remise en cause
fondamentale des principes de l'union
européenne et ses principes sont de deux
ordres 1 le fait que l'union européenne
vise une union sans cesse plus étroite
donc une solidarité comme finalité même
du projet européen et avec l'article 19
la possibilité même pour la cour de
justice de l'union européenne de faire
le droit de dire le droit ce sont ces
deux choses que la pologne conteste et
la deuxième spécificité c'est que dans
tous les autres cas de figure les
tribunaux constitutionnels
les juridictions était considéré comme
légitime
or là on a une vraie question qui se
pose et c'est pour ça que ça soulève les
foudres de beaucoup de détails
d'observateurs politiques c'est que le
tribunal constitutionnel pauline
polonais aujourd'hui et depuis 2015 et
toutes les réformes engagées par la
pologne pour contraindre le système
judiciaire est bien ce tribunal et être
accusé à tort ou à raison d'être
illégitime voire illégal et donc pas
dans son droit donc c'est bien l'état de
droit européen auquel la pologne
s'attaque là etienne campion est toute
la question c'est de savoir ce qu'on met
derrière l'état de droit
c'est une notion qui n'est pas
clairement définie dans les traités
c'est à dire qu'on dit oui mais les
polonais ont adhéré au traité oui sauf
que dans les traités n'est pas question
par exemple de question comme le mariage
pour tous et s'ils sont des questions
morales en fait sur laquelle sur
lesquels les européens de l'ouest pause
lors définition à l'est on a une autre
vision de ce que doit être la démocratie
ont fait passer la souveraineté
nationale et populaire avant l'état de
droit à l'ouest on compte sur les juges
et notamment les juges de la cour
justice de l'union européenne on pourra
parler du processus de fédéralisme
constitutionnel qui est le lieu depuis
l'arrêt costard parce que c'est
essentiel tout repose là-dessus a tandis
qu'à l'est ont fait passer la
souveraineté nationale avant ces
questions d'état de droit et on a une
vision bien différent de ce que les
français peuvent avoir une vision bien
plus pragmatique bien plus lié aux
intérêts économiques il faut être amené
il faut recentraliser la question nous
français on a tendance à voir l'europe
de façon idéologique c'est la phrase de
mitterrand la france notre patrie mais
là l'europe est notre avenir mon projet
d' énormément de choses sur l'europe les
polonais c'est assez simple il ya une
question économique et c'est pour ça
justement que la commission dès le 7
octobre 8 octobre dès le lendemain a
répondu dans vous n'aurez pas les 32
milliards du plan de relance on est en
fait ce qui est intéressant match moi ce
qui m'interesse d'analysé c'est la
réaction des européens la réaction est
là était quoi a été brutal dans un
premier temps elle a été épidermique
mais elle a surtout été idéologique
c'est à dire que clément bonnet europe
ace français les journalistes aussi ont
tout de suite vu un gouvernement
dangereusement réactionnaires se poser
est adroit nous ils ont juste rappeler
un principe essentiel qui est que la
constitution est supérieur aux traités
alors des gens ont fait rappelle que
dans la constitution française et
j'imagine polonaise il ya le fait qu'on
est membre de l'union européenne certes
mais que donc ça nous craint sa tombe de
deux voix bien sûr mais toute la
question est de savoir si
notre constitution
est au dessus ou en dessous du traité
sur l'union européenne
il faut rappeler quelque chose quand
même le traité de rome
est un traité d'ordre du droit
international c'est après avec l'arrêt
costa contre enel que la cour de
l'inflation et de quoi il s'agit puisque
pour vous c'est fondamental c'est
fondamental en fait puisque
dès les années 60 la commission d'une
main et la cour de justice de l'union
européenne
partent avec walter hallstein à l'époque
est peut-être le plus beau le plus
européistes de l'époque dans un procédé
que vous pourrez appeler aujourd'hui
fédéralisme constitutionnel c'est à dire
qu'en gros il ya les constitutions qui
sont là qui sont là la carte d'identité
politique des peuples si vous voulez une
constitution à remonte à une histoire s
est fait dans la dans la douleur gérant
n'est pas arrivé à la conscience 58
comme ça mais ça pose un problème pour
les européistes parce qu'à un moment
donné les politiques qui doivent être
faites pour énormément d'état en même
temps sauf que les constitutions sont
différentes et c'est à ce moment que des
juges qui étaient à l'époque cjc eux qui
dominent la cge décret dans un arrêt qui
s'appelle costa après la révolte des
loups ce qui était l'une 53 mais en gros
que le droit constitutionnel le droit
européen communautaire on appelle à
l'époque il sera supérieur aux
constitutions donc c'est un procédé
furtif sur tille parce que il se fait
par à la une des journaux etc mais bien
réel et à partir de là les juges eux
vont interpréter ce qu'ils veulent des
traités et c'est comme ça qu'on va en
arriver moi j'aime bien rappeler ça aux
gens qui sont à la fois européiste et de
gauche que il ya eu non seulement un
choc juridique avec cet art est là mais
il ya eu un choc libéral libérale voire
ultra libérale grâce à cette
interprétation des traités je rappelle
que dans les années 2000 les juges de la
commission de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne ont pondu des
jurisprudences systématiquement en
faveur notamment du travail de travail
détacher de la mise au ban d'un certain
nombre de droits travail dans certains
pays et c'est donc tout ça est
essentielle et c'est pour ça que la
question démocratique se pose c'est pas
simplement l'état de droit les méfiants
conservateur polonais contre la gentille
européenne c'est une question
fondamentale existentielle qui te
plaisent et finissent tard on oui juste
pour compléter effectivement là c'est
une vision très littérale est c'est fait
mais quand on regarde le fonctionnement
quotidien de l'union européenne et de la
cour de justice il ya un dialogue des
juges en europe qui fonctionne qui est
assez
fin qui est continu entre les juges
nationaux et les juges européens il ya
souvent des points des difficultés qui
sont soulevées par les juridictions
nationales entre la primauté du droit
constitutionnel la primauté du droit
européen et la plupart du temps c'est
ces conflits d'interprétation sont
réglés par le dialogue il ya une forme
de hiérarchie des normes qui s'opère et
tout ça dans une forme de consensus bien
compris en revanche ce qui est certain
c'est que
avec le cas polonais on est aujourd'hui
face à une interrogation
substantielles sur le sens qu'on va
vouloir donner demain à la construction
européenne il va probablement falloir
faire un choix vous l'avez dit on est
certes idéaliste en france et peut-être
pour cela von der leyen partage cette
vision idéale de l'union européenne que
les pères fondateurs avaient avait en
tête il ya plus de 70 ans sur une europe
une véritable europe politique une
europe des idées une europe des libertés
des droits etc maintenant peut-être que
le cas polonais le cas hongrois et
d'autres qui ne manqueront pas d'arriver
nous invite à faire un choix entre cette
vision idéaliste celle qu'on voudrait
voir advenir et une vision plus
pragmatique qui au vu des défis
transnationaux auquel on va devoir faire
face en europe et là j'avais en plus
tous les pays européens que ce soit la
pologne la france l'espagne l'italie la
grèce
un choix entre cette vision idéaliste
une vision pragmatique qui implique un
renoncement mais finalement peut-être
que renoncer c'est faire montre d'un
courage
supérieure à ce qui a été fait
dernièrement et c'est peut-être de
courage dont manquent aujourd'hui les
dirigeants européens mais quand c'est
dessiner la construction européenne et
quand elle a eu véritablement lieu avec
une union européenne avec une assemblée
européenne une commission il y avait
l'idée est surtout une cour de justice
vous avez dit y avait l'idée aussi d'un
droit supranational
mais pas idéal qui s'appliquerait et qui
ferait que par exemple une allemagne qui
tout à coup de basculeraient dans le
nazisme ne pourrait pas faire partie de
l'union européenne c'est à cette idée
derrière c'est que si demain tel ou tel
membre décidé de supprimer les partis
politiques de mettre l'opposition en
prison tena ça ne serait pas possible en
tout cas ils sortiraient de l'union
européenne est-ce que c'est pas là
justement alors non pas qu'on en soit là
avec la pologne c'est parce que je suis
en train de dire mais que c'est là que
ça se joue cette tension c'est de dire
attention on peut discuter de ta truc
mais pas de certains points fondamentaux
il ya eu en fait un débat sur cette
question en effet en 1999 au moment de
l'élection en autriche de l'extrême
droite derrière jorg haider et la
question était de muscler les traités
européens pour empêcher qu'un parti en
l'occurrence d'extrême droite ne
renversent les institutions renverse
l'état de droit et instaure un régime
discriminatoire et c'est donc les
valeurs à l'article 2 du traité d'union
européenne et grandes valeurs
universelles ont été rappelés parmi
lesquels l'état de droit les droits de
l'homme et un article 7 a été ajouté il
faut lire jean claude series qui est un
français qui a été l'un des grands
artisans de cet article 7 qui prévoit
des procédures de sanctions en cas de
violation de l'article 2 le problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'en fait tout le
monde est d'accord sur l'article 2 les
droits de l'homme la non discrimination
la liberté l'égalité tout dépend de
l'interprétation qu'on donne à ces
concepts nous et nous voyons aujourd'hui
une union européenne et notamment à
travers la commission d'ursula von der
leyen qui utilisent les valeurs à
l'article 2 pour les opposer aux valeurs
conservatrices prônée par les élites
centre européenne en pologne et en
hongrie point n'est qu'un exemple au nom
du principe de non discrimination qu un
principe fondamental liste est encore
une fois l'article 2 la commission de
bruxelles met en place une stratégie
visant je cite à promouvoir les droits
lgbt c'est tout à fait légitime sauf que
l'union européenne n'a pas de compétence
en matière sociétale et donc nous avons
là un logiciel progressiste qui vient de
la commission du ciel qui s'opposent à
des volontés nationales qui elles sont
le produit de la souveraineté populaire
puisqu'elle émane d'élections qui ont
fait sortir dès majorité conservatrice
non pas simplement une fois mais parfois
deux fois avec des scores toujours plus
toujours plus importants donc en fait
pour moi la question n'est pas la
question de savoir si nous voulons une
europe idéal et solidaire et une europe
froide et pragmatique il y à une
troisième voie je crois que la troisième
voie c'est la voix des pères fondateurs
c'est la voie de la subsidiarité le
principe de subsidiarité a été rappelé
au moment du traité de maastricht
l'article 3 à b du traité de maastricht
dit que le principe de subsidiarité vise
à préserver la capacité d'action des
états le principe de subsidiarité c'est
au fond l'idée qu'il faut que l'action
se fasse au meilleur échelon possible et
que l'union européenne agisse que
lorsqu'elle peut mieux faire que les
états et le principe de subsidiarité a
lui aussi été rappelé au moment du
traité de lisbonne et prévoit pour
maintenir cette distinction entre ce qui
relève de l'union européenne ce qui
relève de des états à s'étendre
mécanismes notamment la possibilité pour
les parlements nationaux de faire un
certain nombre de remontrance lorsque le
droit de l'union européenne outre passe
son champ d'action légitime vous avez
les parlements nationaux et puis vous
avez aussi les constitutions qui peuvent
servir de contrepoids si vous et moi je
pense qu'il faut émancipé la notion de
contre-pouvoir simplement du cadre
national nous avons besoin de
contre-pouvoir dans le cadre national
dans le cas du face à face entre
citoyens et à il faut les élargir ce
concept au chant de l'union européenne
et prévoir des contrepoids nationaux
lorsque l'union européenne va trop loin
et je crois que lille le concept
d'identité constitue elle est à ce titre
tout à fait intéressant il est rappelé à
l'article 4 du traité l'union européenne
et je donnerai simplement un exemple qui
montre que la constitution les
constitutions peuvent servir de filtre y
compris en france en 1999 lorsque la
france avait signé la charte des langues
régionales et minoritaires jacques
chirac avait demandé au conseil
constitutionnel son avis et le conseil
continue elle avait dit cette charte est
anticonstitutionnelle puisqu'elle va à
l'encontre du principe d'unicité et
d'indivisibilité de la république ce ne
sont pas des valeurs juridique abstraite
ce sont des valeurs historiques
culturelles françaises fondamentalement
républicaines qui sont venus ici
s'opposer à une charte européenne voilà
chaque nation à ses valeurs les
constitutions rappelle aussi des valeurs
historiques je crois qu'il faut en tenir
compte sinon nous n'avancerons pas sur
les sujets sur lesquels l'union
européenne pourrait en revanche
davantage agir
est-ce que c'est quoi le problème pour
vous entre on parle toujours de la
hongrie et de la pologne vis-à-vis de
l'europe de l'ouest par exemple qu'est
ce qui nous sépare qu'est ce qui fait
que éventuellement la commission
européenne pour aller chercher un peu
des poux constamment vous mais chez les
uns et les autres est ce que c'est parce
qu'ils sont fondamentalement
réactionnaire euh oui libéraux ou est ce
qu'il ya un vrai problème c'est tout le
sujet du très bon livre de max
thérouanne que je invite à lire mais
vous m'invitez a cité le philosophe
chantal delsol qu'à une phrase qui
résume assez bien en fait ces clivages
qu'on est en train d'aborder qui dit les
européens regardent à l'est ils voient
des attardés dits dangereux
réactionnaire les européens de l'ouest
les européens de l'est quant à eux ils
regardent à l'ouest et loi des
suicidaires alors la phrase est les
scavo et les poly morte à la polémique
elle est brutale mais il ya tout l'enjeu
qui est l'enjeu des valeurs d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui
j'avais une description assez
matérialiste de désintérêt de la pologne
mais c'est l'ensemble de l'europe qu'une
illusion assez matérialiste aujourd'hui
en réalité on ne raisonne plus que en
chantage aux plans de relance pour la
pologne c'est pas pratique vous disiez
tout à l'heure la moitié des déplacés
qui sont pragmatiques la ursula von der
leyen elle a été pragmatique et guy bop
vous aurez pas l'argent points oui mais
c'est pas ça une communauté politique
une communauté politique c'est une
culture c'est mieux entité sinon volonté
d'être ensemble alors là moi la gauche
nous communal et politique c'est une
constitution déjà depuis montesquieu
c'est ici c'est bien plus bien moins sec
bien moins aride que ce que nous propose
l'union européenne depuis des années la
veille des européennes les les français
mais rejetée ouais c'était tout c'est
tout problème et donc on l'a fait passer
en 2008 par le parlement à l'occasion
d'une trahison nationale de nos députés
traité de lisbonne voilà et on en arrive
à une époque où est bien à la
construction européenne est arrivée à un
point de questionnements existentiels
qu'est ce qu'on fait on avance on
continue à faire exercer le droit à
toujours plus de droits contre les
opinions et le ressenti des gens parce
qu'en fait il ya un décalage entre eux
là où les juges à vence où ils veulent
faire avancer de façon artificielle
union européenne c'est tout le sens qui
s'est passé avec la pologne et le
sentiment européen
des gens dans les gens n'ont qu'un
sentiment
fiona les élites certes une volonté
d'appartenir à l'europe à des trains
parfois un peu plus même londonienne au
mur quesque parisienne ou angevine voilà
c'est comme ça mais
c'est pour ça que le moment qu'on vit
est intéressant il nous amène à nous
poser des questions et alors évidemment
en france on pourrait être confrontée
aux même types de situations mais avec
emmanuel macron
il a été il a en tout cas essayer
d'incarner dernier baroud d'honneur de
la construction européenne avec c'était
de la france allait avoir un effet de
levier pour faire l'europe - ont fait
des records 2017 au moment de son
élection le seul quasiment qui fait
campagne sur l'état de droit européen ce
emmanuel macron oui il n'a pas il reste
est tout à fait dans la ligne du
programme pour lequel il a été élu il a
été clair mais il n'a rien pu faire il
s'est confronté à la volonté réelle
nature réalise nationalement ont fait
essentiellement je veux d'angela merkel
en gros 100 il a eu son grand projet qui
était celui du discours de la sorbonne
et de dire on va faire la souveraineté
européenne
c'est antithétiques par essence puisque
les souverainetés c'est un peuple est ce
qu'il ya un peuple européen il ya des
peuples européens c'est d'essayer des
choses tellement essentielle et c'est
bizarre de les rappeler mais bon et il a
échoué il a échoué parce qu'un gala
merkel était tenu par les intérêts
allemands donc sur le il a obtenu
quelques concessions sur
il n'a pas été beaucoup plus loin que ça
on l'a vu avec la crise du coc vide à
quel point les nations européennes
étaient divisés et je pense qu'on est
susceptible de vivre un retour au
réalisme nationale alors ça sera pas à
cannes emmanuel macron en france c'est
certain mais on voit qu'à l'est ça bouge
peut-être pas dans notre sens a noué
avec nos valeurs je ne suis pas fan des
valeurs une polonaise et hongroise mais
ça peut se passer par je vous interromps
ont fait une pause et on se retrouve
juste après en espérant que carmenna
l'ancien ambassadeur de france en
pologne nous aura rejoint d'ici là
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur le droit de
l'union européenne et sa primauté ou pas
sur les droits de l'actionner avec max
thérouanne gastineau l'auteur de du
nouveau procès de l'est aux éditions du
surf avec joséphine staron qui est
directrice des études et des relations
internationales du think-tank si nokia
avec etienne campion qui est journaliste
à marianne et vice président de
l'association critique de la raison
européenne c'est à sciences po et avec
pierre ménès ancien ambassadeur de
france en pologne l'ancien conseiller de
jacques chirac pour les affaires
européennes quand il voudra bien arriver
parce que les embouteillages sont
paraît-il terrible ce soir dans paris
j'aimerais entendre sur la déclaration
de michel barnier ancien commissaire
européen qui a parlé de souveraineté
juridique de la france en matière
d'immigration je rappelle qu'il est
actuellement candidat à la
présidentielle pour les républicains et
en même temps il est bien placé puisque
c'est lui qui a négocié le bric site
avec les britanniques il est bien placé
pour savoir que l'immigration est une
compétence partagée compétences à la
fois de l'union européenne pour décider
des conditions d'entrée en europe et
puis avec les états qui eux ont le droit
de dire ben nous on veut tant de
d'immigrés et pas plus ou pas - c'est
donc une compétence partagée par les
deux de souveraineté juridique ça veut
dire quoi
je vais film alors ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que la france par exemple
pourrait décider de manière souveraine
sur toutes les questions migratoires
c'est à moitié le cas vous l'avais dit
la souveraineté partagée en matière
migratoire ce qui est intéressant
surtout c'est de comprendre pourquoi
michel barnier parle de ça aujourd'hui
quand on regarde les sondages d'opinion
que ce soit en france ou partout
ailleurs en europe l'une des
préoccupations les plus importantes des
citoyens européens c'est la question
migratoire pourquoi parce qu'en 2015 on
a une crise migratoire très importante à
ces violentes même si elle avait été
prévu et par beaucoup mais en tout cas
rien n'avait été fait pour l'anticiper
et il ya eu un traumatisme depuis donc
les européens le traumatisme est
d'autant plus gros qu on a eu peu
d'immigrés dans son pays vous avez
remarqué notamment voilà en allemagne où
ils en ont pris un million ils sont
moins traumatisés qu'en france paye
peut-être mais quand même il ça dépend
pas ce qu'il faut regarder que les
résultats des dernières élections
l'extrême droite n'a pas faire un score
aussi faible qu'on comprend plus coût
plus faible qu'en france pour l'instant
mais en tout cas c'est une vraie
préoccupation des européens c'est
également une préoccupation pologne
c'est une préoccupation hongrie ça
explique d'une certaine manière pourquoi
les peuples européens peuvent être
frileux vis-à-vis de l'ue a de temps en
temps et surtout sur cette question
migratoire mais ce qui est certain c'est
que les européens attendent beaucoup de
lui sur ces questions migratoires on
n'est pas prêt pour la prochaine crise
depuis 2015 presque rien je n'irai pas
rien mais presque rien n'a été fait au
niveau de l'union européenne pour
anticiper une prochaine crise on a des
tas de négociation d'états de débat mais
ça n'a rien donné concrètement dans les
faits si ça recommence et ça devrait
recommencer tous les signaux sont sont
sur le disent nous prévienne nous ne
sommes pas prêts et ça les citoyens le
centre bien alors michel barnier tentent
de parler de souveraineté juridique pour
rassurer oui mais et alors même si on
est souverain juridiquement que ferait
ton que ferait ton de plus que ferais tu
on différemment il ya une initiative en
ce moment de 12 pays européens la
plupart sont des pays de l'est mais je
crois qu'on est également le danemark et
la grèce donc un pays du nord est un
pays du sud qui ont déclaré vouloir
construire des murs des barbelés comme
ça a été fait en 2015 16 17 pour contrer
les flux migratoires et la commission
européenne a tout de suite rétorqué qu'
elle ne financerait pas l n'aiderait pas
à financer des projets de construction
de murs ou de barbelés mais ça montre
bien que c'est contraire aux traités
c'est contraire aux traités mais ce sont
des états qui cherchent une solution qui
n'est pas la bonne parce que de toute
manière quand on veut quitter son pays
quand on fuit son pays c'est qu'on n'a
pas le choix et donc ils trouveront
d'autres routes d'autres chemins ça ne
peut être qu'une solution temporaire
mais ce que ça dit en revanche c'est que
les états et même les états qu'on peut
dire être plus eurosceptiques que
d'autres même me suis pas certain que la
pologne et la hongrie soit
eurosceptiques puisqu'elle ne veulent
pas sortir de l'union européenne et bien
même ces états là veulent une solution
une solution européenne à la crise
migratoire mais reconnaissez que la
grande bretagne une des raisons du bric
site c'est justement parce que les
anglais enfin les britanniques ne
voulaient plus se plier à une politique
commune en matière d'immigration
ils ont pris leurs responsabilités ils
ont quitté l'union européenne mais ce
qui a surtout motiver les britanniques
c'était l'ami l'immigration interne
migrations intra européennes au ps qui a
un peu différent là c'était le principe
de schengen qui était carrément remis en
question et ils ont fait leur choix ils
sont sortis tous les états peuvent faire
ce choix large acte moment mais je pense
qu aucun aucun aujourd'hui n'a envie de
le faire dans aucun n'a envie de sortir
de l'union européenne même si aucun
enfin où de plus en plus nombreux sont
ceux qui ne veulent plus respectés des
traités ces traités là c'est très
intéressant à tous mais en tout cas une
évolution est possible et je pense que
aujourd'hui le champ des possibles est
ouvert on est face à une forme de crise
institutionnelle comme vous le rappeliez
tout à l'heure qui est propice à une
refondation du projet européen autour de
nouveaux traités et pierre ménat viens
nous rejoindre les ya pas de problème
bonjour bonsoir diplomate ancien
directeur europe du ministère des
affaires étrangères vous avez été en
ambassadeur de france en pologne mais
aussi en roumanie en tunisie et aux
pays-bas vous êtes l'auteur de chercheur
up désespérément paru en 2019 et de dix
questions sur l'europe post covidien
paru en fin 2020 les deux aux éditions
de l'harmattan depuis tout à l'heure on
parle de la pologne et de cette espèce
d'opposition enfin une position très
marqué avec avec soit l'europe de
l'ouest soit avec la commission
européenne alors pour vous est-ce que
l'homme est ce que la pologne est dans
son droit parce que c'est ça qui nous
occupe parce qu'elle est légitime ne pas
vouloir
à
s'attaquer d'approché avant dé ryan aux
fondations de l'union européenne alors
je crains de répéter peut-être ce qui a
été dit je suis désolée par avance si
c'est le cas
je pense qu'il ya deux aspects en effet
et vous les avez résumé dans votre
question l'aspect juridique et respecte
politique sur le plan juridique il ya un
débat peut-être qu'il a été abordée
entre eux alors sur la question du de
primauté du droit européen sur le droit
interne il ya en gros les institutions
européennes qu'ils considèrent dont on
va dire grosso modo que le droit
européen et de toute façon
supérieur au droit interne qu'il
s'agisse des traités ou du droit dérivé
et puis il ya un certain nombre de
juridictions nationales mais c'est
certainement cela a été évoqué qui
considère que la constitution et c'est
de cela qu'il s'agit dans la ré édition
du 7 octobre de la cour constitionnelle
la constitution polonaise est supérieur
au traité donc ça c'est l'aspect
juridique on peut en débattre très
longtemps et je pense que comme souvent
dans les querelles de juristes il est
difficile d'y voir clair l'aspect
politique et peut-être
plus clair parce que dans cet arrêt on
voit bien ce dont il s'agit d'abord il
s'agit pas seulement du droit dérivé
mais du traité lui même traité sur
l'union européenne
puisque des pans entiers sont considérés
comme non compatible avec la
constitution polonaise et puis
deuxièmement la matière
dont il s'agit c'est à dire
l'indépendance de la justice est une
matière qui
relève de l'état de droit et à ce titre
qui relevait des conditions d'adhésion
constitution de rappeler c'est le
premier des critères politiques de
critères politiques pour des saluts donc
après il ya d'autres d'autres
l'argumentation possible on peut dire
que la pologne mais la france aussi ont
ratifié les traités donc ils l'ont
inséré dans leur ordre interne mais je
crois qu'il ya surtout un problème
politique et ce problème politique il et
les tripes c'est d'abord l'aspiration à
la souveraineté de la pologne d'un côté
de l'autre côté son désir très large la
scion de rester dans l'union européenne
pour tout un tas de raisons parce que
c'était un long combat parce que cela
aussi comporte certains nombre
d'avantagés financiers comme vous le
savez et puis il y à aussi la question
doit s'insérer dans cette affaire on
peut discuter de la façon dont ça
s'insère l'attachement aussi de la
pologne lien très attentifs et les
difficultés sur ses difficultés
actuelles avec
l'administration américaine la nouvelle
illustration américaine qui peuvent la
poussée peut-être à se rapprocher de
l'union ce qui fait que finalement ce
qui est ressorti du conseil européen
c'est aussi c'est quand même une volonté
de discuter plutôt qu'un blocage total
mais alors wimax se ferait sur
le rapport à ce que disait pierre
bennett et par rapport ce que vous avez
pu dire tout à l'heure pour vous tous
pour vous de vous dis c'est un moment
très intéressant de toute façon oui
parce que en effet
le juge polonais a dénoncé l'article 1
et l'article 19 du traité de l'union
européenne ce a été rappelée donc
l'article 19 qui traitent des
compétences de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne et l'article 1er qui
me semble fondamental puisque cet
article premier rappelle que l'union
vise le projet européen vise une union
sans cesse plus étroite entre les
peuples d'europe et ce sans cesse plus
étroite qui justifie aux yeux de
certains partisans de la construction
européenne
je dirais d'allant supranationaux le
fait que la commission s'occupe d'un
certain nombre de sujets qui ne veut pas
prévus à l'origine dans les traités et
puis vous avez quand même un article 4
qui fixe des limites à cet article et
l'article 4 rappelle que l'union
européenne respecte les identités
nationales je cite le traité l'article 4
c'est à dire la structure politique et
constitutionnel fondamental des états
membres donc vous avez à la fois un
processus qui justifie des élans supra
nationaux et des limites qui justifie un
certain attachement aux prérogatives
régaliennes et la société des
installations alors face à ces deux
articles qui ont tendance peu apte à
s'opposer je crois qu'il faut trouver un
juste milieu est ce juste milieu me
semble être inscrit dans l'idée même de
subsidiarité comme je l'avais évoqué des
thèmes campion oui mais je souscris à ce
qui a été dit mais je pense aussi que
c'est intéressant de dévoilement une
clarification en fait mon jeu suivant et
la pologne sortira par l'union
européenne ça c'est clair a pas de paul
exit je pense même pas que c'est un paul
exit juridique en fait il ya ce sont
seulement des articles qui est monté
rejetée mais à le traiter en lui-même
bon mais sa maman clarification pour qui
pour les français pour les bons pour les
nations européennes mais pour les
français et on voit qu'un effort est
fait massa qui jure que je trouve
intéressant dans l'offre partisane
française je m'explique je trouve que
pendant 20 ans les politiciens français
qu'ils soient au pouvoir ou non ont été
très floue sur la question l'union
elle-même pendant les élections
européennes c'est à dire qu'en gros on a
des grands principes on a même parfois
parler d'europe sociale je passe je me
souvenais ça fait 20 ans fait que la
gauche pour essayer d'avoir une offre
qui se distinguent guingamp libéraliste
toujours plus effréné nous parle
d'europe sociale c'est une chimère n'a
jamais lieu elle n'aura jamais lieu
d'ailleurs la gauche le paye
électoralement
à droite la question se pose en d'autres
termes et on en parlait à l'instant
c'est la question de l'immigration bon
et donc il ya différents
courants politiques essayent de composés
qui essayent d'inventer des choses là on
à michel barnier qui nous parle de
bouclier juridique bon donc y aura tout
un combat de terminologie voyez pour
expliquer deux tours précédents tourner
autour dans la réalité dans le discours
et dans l'offre politique proposant
comme tous les candidats disent que
s'ils sont élus demain ils iront
renégocier les traités
ils ont tous essayé de vaincre on le
sentait assez clair il a dit qu'il
allait plus loin mais effectivement en
fait on se heurte
sans cesse depuis des années en france
entre
les grands discours les grandes
intentions politiques et la réalité une
fois élu au cesci a perdu hollande bon
et donc
en fait c'est tout principe de l'europe
et il se peut qu'elle a dedans vous
pourrez dire qu'en termes freudien il
l'européisme prend ses désirs pour des
réalités il ya toujours une logique de
désir on pourra changer les choses on
peut faire avec l'europe on peut faire
le social on peut même faire
l'immigration pour à la réguler tout
pourra se faire en contradiction totale
avec la réalité des traités tout mais
aujourd'hui j'ai on essaie d'avancer
justement cette europe et ce dont vous
parlez il est partagé à la fois par les
polonaises vous l'avez dit sommet
européen est à leur manière mais
qu'est-ce qui oppose je leur posais la
question tout à l'heure et maxi awan
écrit un livre sur le sujet mais vous
permet d'être qu'avait été ambassadeur
en pologne notamment qu'est ce qui fait
que constamment la commission européenne
l'europe de l'ouest on pourrait dire
s'opposent à des pays comme la pologne
et la hongrie qu'est ce qui les
différencie
d'après vous de nous je crois que ces
pays il faut jamais l'oublier
mon vécu sous le régime de la
souveraineté limitée pendant
alors en ce qui concerne la pologne non
seulement pendant les 45 ans de
communisme mais auparavant pendant des
siècles en fait par deux siècles et déjà
avant l'adhésion moi je suis arrivé en
pologne
en septembre 2004 quelques mois après
l'adhésion c'est des bars étaient encore
assez présents et notamment de la part
du pis qui à l'époque dans l'opposition
mais qui ensuite accéder au pouvoir et
l'idée c'est on n'a pas on s'est pas
débarrassé de notre souveraineté de la
tutelle de moscou pour avoir celle de
bruxelles donc ils ont essayé alors il
ya eu une période ensuite le pis était
au pouvoir entre 2005 2007 ensuite il ya
eu une assez longue période de 7 ans
pendant laquelle
pour reprendre les termes qui ont été
utilisés le gouvernement était plutôt
européiste avec le gouvernement de
donald tusk
et puis ensuite le pire est revenu au
pouvoir mais de façon beaucoup plus
solide avec une majorité absolue et là
ils ont dû tenir tenir compte de leur
électorat mais c'est vrai aussi en gris
c'est vrai
voilà mon reçoit sète et parviennent oui
alors s'assurer augmenter encore plus
effectivement il ya un nationalisme
hongrois pour ce qui concerne la pologne
c'est plus du souverainisme que du
nationalisme ce corps que des aspects
nationaliste donc ils ont été conduits
si vous voulez pour pouvoir j'irai pour
répondre à leurs électeurs ils ont été
conduits à prendre un certain nombre de
décisions qui sont un peu discutable
assez discutable de la barre de la
commission par ailleurs la commission
faux-pas faut pas se le cacher parfois
on fait trop parce que ça a été dit tout
à l'heure dans le traité il ya des
limites il ya des compétences exclusives
ya le principe de proportionnalité
le fait que la subsidiarité ça veut dire
simplement que quand nos compétences
n'est pas attribué à l'union
elle à partir aux états et la justice
n'est pas une compétence de l'union une
compétence partagée mais l'organisation
de la justice est une compétence des
états donc dans ces conditions je pense
qu'il ya des responsabilités de côté
alors peut-être que maintenant vu la
situation
qu'elles ont et n'est pas revenue
peut-être que il peut y avoir
effectivement un dialogue prévu que
peut-être que
déjà le premier ministre polonais a
indiqué qu'ils renonçaient un des
aspects comme c'est ce qui est sorti du
conseil européen de vendredi dernier qui
relançait un des aspects de
la réforme qui était la création de
chambres disciplinaires on ne sait pas
très bien dans quelles conditions mais
aujourd'hui on n'est pas n'a pas
l'impression d'être dans un combat
frontal on va peut-être y arrive
effectivement parce que il ya 2 1 peut
de part et d'autre des élections qui se
préparent et donc la positionnement
politique je pense que il est possible
de parvenir à un compromis max à wang a
sinon vous qui avez écrit le nouveau
procès de l'est
cette histoire de chambres
disciplinaires qui est une des raisons
pour lesquelles de le bisbilles entre la
pologne et le et le
et l'union européenne est-ce que ça
c'est bah si c'était nous qui a vu entre
ces deux schémas progrès un projet de
chambre disciplinaire ou l'allemagne
personne n'aurait rien dit et est ce que
ça veut dire qu'on les a dans le
collimateur un peu comme on adopte
collimateur victor banny qui quand il a
une idée on la regarde à trois forces
disant qu'est ce que ça cache inception
on peut on peut quand même se poser la
question
en effet l'idée a été d'introduire une
chambre disciplinaire qui d'après
certains certains juristes
pose le risque de remettre en cause
l'indépendance l'indépendance de la
justice au nom d'un principe de
précaution judiciaire l'union européenne
dit stop à cette réforme un principe un
tel principe de précaution pourrait
faire jurisprudence et aussi s'appliquer
à d'autres états nous avons souvent en
france un débat sur le lien qui relie le
parquet au ministère de la justice donc
pourrait très bien imaginer demain
l'union européenne s'immiscer dans la
réforme judiciaire française et imposer
un logiciel qui serait différent de
notre histoire puisque le lien qui relie
le parquet au ministère de justice s'est
largement n'est plus aussi fort qu'avant
mais il existe encore il est le produit
de notre histoire notre histoire
républicaine simplement peut-être pour
compléter ce que disait monsieur
l'ambassadeur est en effet ce qui nous
différencie je pensais deux choses la
première chose ça a été dit une histoire
de petites nations qui ont été longtemps
dominé par des empires et qu'ils sont
dominés pour citer l'historienne
alexandra laignel par une psychologie de
l'incertitude nationale elles sont
convaincues que leur devenir est
toujours à tout moment être mise entre
parenthèses et la deuxième chose c'est
je dirais sur le terrain culturel pas
simplement sur les questions familiales
et sociétal vous avez une débat sur
qu'est ce que la nation je crois que au
fond l'europe occidentale à une
conception habermas yens de la nation
donc je mets que j'ai engagé la peur de
your gun habermas le grand philosophe
allemand jeudi grand sens sans ironie il
a une très grande influence et au fond
il a cherché à redéfinir le lien qui
unit les citoyens à leur état en
expliquant que pour éviter de retomber
dans le nationalisme soit l'exaltation
de spécificités culturelles et
spirituelles nationale il fallait
construire ce lien sur le droit nous
sommes fiers d'être français parce que
notre constitution nous assure un
certain nombre de droits et de libertés
points eh bien les hongrois et les
polonais disent ce n'est pas simplement
la nation la nation ce n'est pas
simplement une entité juridique c'est
aussi une patrie charnelle c'est aussi
un enracinement c'est aussi une histoire
des moeurs des traditions et d'ailleurs
nos moeurs nos traditions hongroise et
polonaise sont les diverses modalités
d'expression d'un terreau
civilisationnel européen façonné par des
siècles de christianisme donc vous avez
au fond une conception plus identitaire
que juridique de la nation qui me
semble-t-il complète notre vision a new
west européens plus juridique que
culturelles les deux font partie de
l'héritage européen c'est d'ailleurs la
promesse de l'union européenne quand on
regarde la devise de l'ua s'est unie
dans la diversité
c'est une promesse extrêmement
ambitieuse
qui est d'essayer de concilier
constamment la préservation de la
diversité intra européennes qui existe
et qui est qui et dans l'article 2 comme
valeur fondamentale cette diversité doit
être préservé et valorisé et en même
temps fournir un cadre institutionnel et
réglementaire
capable de jeter des règles communes des
règles du jeu communes aux états
européens pour avancer ensemble sur des
projets moi j'aimerais revenir sur un
point je trouve que les visions sont
presque un peu pessimiste quant à
l'avenir de l'union européenne depuis
quelques années on a des avancées même
en matière d'europe sociale c'est vrai
qu' on est loin on est extrêmement loin
d'une europe sociale mais il y à des
volontés et quand emmanuel macron parle
à la sorbonne de souveraineté européenne
certes on en est encore très loin mais
il ya cette volonté elle est peut-être
idéal mais elle s'inscrit selon moi sur
un principe de réalité politique qui est
qu'on n'a pas le choix et peut-être que
les polonais les hongrois s'en rendre
compte quand ils sont plus de 70 % à à
vouloir rester dans l'union européenne
on n'a pas le choix que d'être européen
que d'être dans une forme de solidarité
européenne aujourd'hui parce qu'on n'est
pas tout seul parce qu'on est face à un
contexte international qui nous oblige
aujourd'hui à penser au commun donc
certes le souverainisme et la nation ont
toujours un rôle à jouer et il faut
revoir la subsidiarité il faut
réinterroger cette répartition des
compétences qui peut être n'est plus
adaptée qui probablement n'est plus
adapté aux défis d'aujourd'hui et de
demain mais en revanche de là à penser
qu'il faille revenir à une souveraineté
nationale sur beaucoup dans beaucoup de
domaines je pense que c'est se tromper
et surtout faire un choix historique qui
serait contraire à nos intérêts mais je
me permets nantes il ya eu pendant très
longtemps un vaste consensus politique
en faveur de la construction européenne
même jacques chirac dont vous avez été
le conseiller à un moment qui avait joué
le lentilles européen est revenu très
vite dans le rang les français sont
majoritairement pour rester dans
l'europe les candidats qui ont se sont
aventurés sur le terrain d'un freak site
donc jamais fait grand chose aux
élections est ce qu'il y a pas en ce
moment à la fois tout le monde en france
veut rester dans l'union européenne mais
en même temps tout le monde a l'air de
vouloir faire semblant de la combattre
ou est ce qu'il n'ya pas de mauvaise foi
est ce que finalement on se sert pas de
l'union européenne en france pour faire
passer voulu mettre sur le dos tout ce
qu'on assume pas bien sûr te fait raison
s'il ya cela il ya aussi un déficit je
crois d'explication ce que je dis dans
mon jeu c'est écrit dans les deux livres
que vous avez bien voulu citer il ya un
déficit d'explication je prends un
exemple qui vient d'être cité tu as fait
de façon remarquable la question de la
souveraineté européenne donc c'est une
notion qu'on a avancé et en fait je ne
suis pas sûr que les européens aient
d'abord les français les allemands ou
qui que ce soit d'ailleurs sache
exactement ce que c'est parce que cela a
été dit il ya des domaines où la
compétence de l'union et exclusive et là
on peut parler de souveraineté
européenne mais en fait ces domaines
sont assez limitées vous savez c'est la
concurrence le marché intérieur
le
droite d'où les affaires de douane et
puis les deux nouvelles subir deux plus
récentes sur la pêche et la monnaie
commune la monnaie unique pour les pays
de la zone euro fait il ya très peu de
confidences exclusives dans les autres
domaines notamment les domaines de
souveraineté habituelle mais classique
si vous voulez que sont
la police la justice affaires étrangères
défense nous sommes là dans des domaines
de compétences nationales de la notion
de souveraineté européenne il faut
expliquer que c'est en partie allait en
partie exercées par les états mais on
peut très bien considéré que les états
agissent au nom l'europe c'est ce qui
serait intéressant si oui et par l'union
européenne elle même et là on est on est
au coeur du problème parce que
nous sommes ne nous nous sommes à vielle
ta nation n'a pas je pense que même pour
les français même si en effet vous avez
raison il ya des courants de pensée qui
rappelle que c'est d'abord l'état nation
est ensuite l'europe c'est vrai mais je
crois que
l'on pourrait expliquer aux français que
la construction européenne n'est en
aucun cas
l'abandon de la nation et de ce point de
vue la sphère polonaise est un tel je
pense est intéressante parce que j'ai
entendu commission européen récemment
pour ne pas le citer astier thierry
breton qui disait au lièvre c'est comme
aux états unis c'est comme aux états
unis à vous n'avez parlé malgré les
envies désolé mais cet exemple n'est à
mon avis n'est pas totalement approprié
pourquoi parce que vous n'avez dire
certains disent on est en europe d'un
système fédéral alors on n'est pas rien
d'un système fédéral au sens où un
certain nombre de compétences ont été
délégués mais aux états unis le système
fédéral fait que l'état quand il délègue
des compétences nédélec totalement
totalement c'est à dire que on n'imagine
pas par exemple pour adopter un budget
ou un plan de relance vous n'imaginez
pas le président des états unis convoqué
et gouverneur des 50 états où madame
merkel ou son successeur mais le
chancelier chose bientôt convoqué les 16
länder c'est impossible donc nous avons
quand même une construction européenne
union européenne qui préserve les états
et c'est pourquoi je pense que dans les
domaines de souveraineté en effet si on
veut progresser vers 6 europe 1 dont
vous parliez et qui est très important
je crois qu'il faut trouver peut-être de
nouvelles modalités notamment sur les
nouveaux de nouveaux sujets que sont la
politique étrangère la défense moi je
propose
dans mon premier livre dans mon livre je
me propose peut-être mon deuxième saut
si vous n'êtes pas le dernier je propose
qu'on reprenne une idée on va
l'appliquer à la lettre mais qu'on
reprenne une idée qu'être qui avait été
présenté par le général de gaulle sous
la forme du plan fouchet
qui le plan fouchet en 61 était un plan
précisément de l'union politique et de
défense certains disent général de
gaulle était anti européen il a proposé
le plan le plus ambitieux pour la
politique étrangère la défense et
peut-être aussi la culture la justice la
police mais avec une construction à la
base et étatiques et pourquoi ça avait
été écarté à l'époque d'abord parce que
il y avait le problème du royaume uni et
qui nos partenaires voulaient que le
royaume uni soit dedans donc aujourd'hui
départ d'eric 1 voilà mais il est parti
doivent ils voulaient surtout je crois
qu'ils soient dedans pour justement
porté aussi sont en somalie et les
ricains et puis deuxièmement sur toutes
nos alliés continuent c'est le problème
continue aujourd'hui nos alliés ont
toujours vous dit tout ce qui concerne
la défense faire étrangères on peut pas
concevoir des efforts européens qu'ils
soient pas sous l'égide de l'otan ça
c'est un blocage évidemment qui continue
aujourd'hui bien que l'otan n'est plus
du tout le même sens que dans les années
60 parce que dans les années 60 le temps
c'était un organe de défense contre gros
l'union soviétique et le fait que les
américains
s'appuyait sur nous en paix en disant
vous allez nous aider dans un grand
ensemble commun qu'on appelle le temps à
lutter contre eux union soviétique
aujourd'hui le problème est un peu
différent mais cela dit ce qui est
intéressant c'est aussi que point pays
comme la pologne certes l'union
soviétique n'est plus l'ennemi mais la
russie si je puis dire ici donc ne nous
avait pas aidés
n'est pas considéré comme un grand ami
voulait donc et n'oubliez pas une chose
c'est que
monsieur kaczinsky qui est le président
de parti droit et justice son frère qui
était président et est mort dans un
accident d'avion lorsque ils ont atterri
paul précisément la cérémonie où on
aurait dû
voir une sorte de pardon pour le
massacre de katyn donc ceci est resté
dans la psychologie de la famille qu'est
ce qu'ils furent obligés de vous
intéresser si on a déjà dépassé le temps
imparti merci tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]